こんにちははじめ冊をです官兵衛が降る日
どう過ごしでしょうか今日はちょっとオサレな感じに行こうと思っています
ああすみません皆さんの家テレビって置いてありますかね
実は僕で一人暮らしを始めてから方々
テレビが見なくなったんですよなんでかっていうとは考えしたと時間がなかったとして
もったいないっていうか時間がすごい取られるしなんかね痴漢のもったいないというか
何か急に見なくなってそう想定日があること自体顔なんか japan
になって j 日をよ化したりしてもテレビがないんですけどもヘビがないって言っ
たら何が一番困ると思いますか
その通りニュースが見れなくなるんですよ硫酸の雑木はですね
社会から取り残されてしまいますなんかネットとかで自分の好きなニュースとかを
調べるから自分の好きなことの情報しか入ってこない
今日中で天気予報との僕見ないか
雨が降るということを知らなかったんで洗濯物が全部出てマジ切れそうでした
いい形のなるんですよねずっと子情報仕入れる江南でのベースとなるものつまりみんな
でテレビだね
テレビとベースになるものが僕にはないのでまあこういうことになっちゃったわけです
よね
そんな僕にとってゆくなアプリを見つけました結構
有名だから知ってる人もいると思うんですけどもグノシーというアプリがございま
2014年にもっともダウンロードされている無料のニュースアプリでございます
2015年の4月現在も900万ダウンロードされ店でニュースアプリ大みたいなもう
ニュースアプリはこれみたいな感じなんです僕は
使ったことがありません本当に情報第一よく
エンタメコラムスポーツ経済など猫様々な残念のニュースの情報が見れるっていう上で
ございます
これは使ったことないから何とも言えないんだけどねじゃあこの動画は企業とのタイ
アップと間なんですけども
多分月で使う気がしますマジでねちょっと乗馬なさせに行ったよ
思ってるかもよ
入っていうこちら good シートトップ画面でございます
方小泉トピックが分かれているみたいですねトピック
埋入するスポーツあとねグルメ社会経済政治
パンチ特集国際クリックまあそういう感じで色々あります来年六から出ると知る方法
できるのそんなのパスタンププレゼントか
あーなるほどねスタンプオーグルとでにこのスタンプは持っているためブレッド出来
ませんですねたくさん出るとちょっとしブレークされているかもしれないということ
らしいですで death note ドラボカすんの
すげー
あーやばいですよねならですなくここで並び替えをすると自分の見たい奴だけは
並べ替えれるって言うのもあります
約4割の男子が好き女子は稀に乗っている時がいいと判明
気になりますがこれでコラムゲーム結構僕好きな戦術というよりも
春風を感じると恋したいことがないとでしょうかじでんしゃ館
され女子はモテるわかる2人をよく見える
わかるさわやかわかる応援したになるわかる人が名古屋さを感じさせるわかる
チャリダー c 花ピック
これわかりますあの女の子事例車乗ってるとなんか北
好きですなんかねえ
en ジレーサーってのはな人ってやつが分かりますこういう感じでいろんな音
エンタメスポーツコラムとか面白とがグルメとかも様々なニュースがこうコンテンツは
記されてめちゃくちゃ見やすい感じになっております見出しだけで版って書いてあるの
がボク的にはすごい見やすいと思っていますされニュース機能なんて生で
柞木のまま暗転ところ全部のジーノすごい
ところはですね今 a 棟ほど少年ジャンプ+全ツを保護してみましょう
follow
きたきたきたきたきたそう開きたいさんなんとですね
今美濃市からで小ジャンプ+の漫画金読めるって言うことを聞いております
あ宇宙はつらいよだ
ガチじゃんこれいやるろうに剣心はおすすめですぼく個人的にこれはれダディ某書いて
た人のヘアー
好きな柄の勝つというわけでこういうですねいろいろなニュースがカテゴリー別に見れ
たり
ニュースアプリなのにジャンク+のマーカーが読めたりするという感じでございます
視力0点で所視力1.0乗せ回復してみた
の頻度で違うかも iphone ケース twitter の真鯛の画像まとめって
言う奴らじゃないですか
これに乗ってるこの鏡で自撮りしたら一気
リーダーの iphone 傷つくった会でっていうこの
この人は僕のツイッターの友達です
僕はいつもそういうのばっかり3つあるでちょっとこれからあげますよね光栄だ国際と
か政治とかさん経済とかこういうのをみたほうがいいのかもしれませんね
はいどうでしたでしょうかけどしなぜ僕のテレビないかティっな
自分が必要としない情報もたくさん入ってくるじゃないですか
番組とかも決まっているとは仕方ないんですけどもなんか僕それってすっごい時間の女
だなって思うんですよ
阿部ぜテレビが食べてるわけじゃないですけどもうその猫いくのシートがニュースのア
プリっていうのは自分が欲しいと思った情報だけをピックアップしてそれでも情報入れ
られるって2ダチョウ方が少ないんですよね
すごい情報を集めるときにはとても効率的だと思っております俺がでテレビ見ないのも
ちゃんと理由があるんですよ
これからさとグノシーを見て国際的な社会的なニュースもうちょっと
仕入れようと思いますどこの水をテレビ見てる人はこういうアプリっとでも便利ですよ
アートやだし載ってたぞニュースいやらしい見てるか
グノシーのニュースに載ってたぞという意味でグノシー
いうアプリの紹介でございましたあいさーしとるだけでも全然いいと思うんで
まずべし室アプリ的なレベルだと思います今日は雨がひどいよね
ベルトしますおやすみー
ん